من سرابي خلافه الى واقع الفلول الجيوب
والسجون داعش الغابه رايته السوداء عن
اراد ارهاقتها سيطرته المنتهيه فهل انتهى
مشروعه في الصوره العامه وقياسا بالجهود
الدوليه للتحالف والولايات المتحده خصوصا
المهم اكتملت خطره الارهاب انتقل على
المقياس الامريكي الرسمي من المرتبه
الاولى قبل عام 2021 الى الرابعه وذلك
لتصفيه اكثر من 12 قياديه لداعش في سنوات
الثلاث التي اعقبت اعلنهازيمته واكثر من
600 عنصر العام الماضي واحده في مئه
وعشرين عمليا الى التحالف فهل انتهى
المشروع
هناك خريطه واعده جديده لاعاده هيكله داعش
وبيئه خصبه لتجديد خطره العالمي القاره
السمراء في الكثير من دول التي تعاني
فراغا سياسيا امنيا
اراضا والارهاب وان كان رغما عنها في 13
بلدا على الاقل يتمركزوا داعش بما يقرب من
20 فرعا في 9 منها احدثه الفروع داعش
الساحل الذي اعلن عنه في مارس الماضي وفي
موزمبيق في مايو سنخوض اكثر في الجغرافيا
بعد قليل لكن لن نخفي الاداء الابرز
لتوسيعها وهي الدعايه ولها يخصص التنظيم
عناصر حول العالم بعضهم متطوعون بقرشفون
يترجمون وينشرون رسائل على الانترنت
حضرت مقاله في صحيفه داعش الاسبوعيه اسمها
النبا على الالتحاق الى فروع افريقيا
وبالعمل الشبكي المعهود نشرت الصحيفه
تسجيلات من سوريا والعراق تهنئ المقاتلين
في القاره السمراء رسائل متعدده اللغات
والانجليزيه منها مهمه وذلك بحسب مركز
مكافحه الارهاب
اثمرت مع داعش خرسان بالتحديد
مهاجمتي الولايات المتحده وفي حرب
الاساسيه ضد طالبان وان قللت الحركه من
اثر التنظيم
اه دارين اريد
اي برنامج
الاسلاميه قادت على 98 من اوتاره التنظيم
لا يشكل مصدر قلق لافغانستان او تحديدا من
الداخل لدول الجوار